você não volta
só que quem fala em mudar que estamos
aqui mais um dia no brasil e vejam só
como eu tenho o meu quarto isso a cada
dia que passa fica pior lei a roupa da
cama já está no chão ou ainda o lá o que
faz acreditar viril editar vídeo
olha sabe que chegamos a 50 mil
comentários já não gostava de hoje está
muito sério em dois povos mostrar o
resto 40 anos começaram de que o vídeo é
a minha mesa continua assim no duche
chocolate batata ou bebida energética e
tem que os gritos onde andamos com bola
eo teleférico animal ainda está aqui só
tem coisa agora é só com ela não tem é
que tem muito cheiro já tem muita pouca
roupa e porque eu tenho pouca roupa
porque minha roupa toda suja aqui no
quarto eu acho que eu vá lavanderia né
o tufão que aquilo que está fazendo aí
meu
como assim mas como é que está aqui ó
exportador está virado ao contrário meu
tá muito desarrumado esse quarto poder
tem 40 por todo lado mas cuenca mais
caos aqui mais roupa ali window queijo
que não basta fazer o windows vista e
windows não é meu e eu não sei ainda mas
eu não sei porque o pessoal usa papel
higiênico envolve só administrar a casa
do rei em uma toalha meu e tá tudo sujo
nisso mas não só essa confusão jogo 4 a
casa está tudo arrumado só que não
aquela que eu sou assim e eu juntos
vamos ver no estado destas entendem não
não gosto que se esticou e estupidez do
corpo porque nunca assim eu não encaro
assim meu como assim quando o futuro
justo ou não cabe assim tanto como não
caiu ontem mas foi cali e muita coisa
aqui eu porque o que está a fazer e item
um chinelo tem um chinelo aqui porque
qualquer sua loja está na altura de
chamar a empregada ou então um dia o
próprio romário quando acho que nem vou
chamar a empregada porque isso aqui tá
tudo em cima do goleiro
hoje está brasil e não deve ser brasil a
chuva não é isso ou então quero aqui
fazer não fala porque o quarto vai lá
fazer o quarto vai melhor com um óptimo
bom é fofo gosto acho que ele tá mas
essa meta ontem nós vamos fazer uma
coisa brutal que nunca tinha feito nós
vamos andar de helicóptero no
helicóptero sabe que helicóptero e avião
fazia de tudo está o helicóptero do do
telescópio fizemos um passeio turístico
pelo rio a campanha junto feira entre
duas montanhas que muito altas
basicamente nesta viagem toda não já
voamos tipo mais quatro vezes que enviam
só pra vir pra cá helicóptero entanto
fere um valor muito alto no 12º andar
psi é voar por mim eu já perdi tudo
melhor porque tinha muito medo de voar
com já bastante tempo aqui no ar ea
japan disse meena vamos voar outra vez
nem por que não experimentar as atrações
além do rock in rio e em termos de
quotas vez portugal tem mais nove horas
de avião é muito burro voar e nós temos
a ganhar muito inscritos com
visualizações boas estou muito contente
mesmo portanto campanha e físico mega
online e se vocês não foi inscrito no
canal inscrevam porque é muito
importante ser e boston aos alimentos já
temos quatro xícaras 3 mil em dois
milhões oitocentos e quarenta e três mil
inscritos meu é muito inscrito e já sabe
quando os caras 3 milhões de vôos
custaram conectar a namorada 2
então é isso quanto mais rápido chegar
aos 3 milhões mais capital o vídeo é
baseado em um vídeo especial nem e
quando escala portugal também vou fazer
o comunitário judô fez gol porque essa
foi a meta do último vídeo de
escaramuças 50 mil comentários e nós
conseguimos chegar eu acho que já tem 60
mil e não só enquanto eu como o quarto
mais um só que o perseguia e cópia jd
que nunca
num espaço muito grande olha só vamos à
tarde no encontro
[Música]
então não quer que jasper melhor semana
da minha melhor sempre muito muito bom
né só foi muito bom esta viagem séria de
quaresma não tinham nada é muito barulho
mas já em baixa paisagem é linda e foi
só foi muito louca viagem sério foi
mesmo muito bom tem aquela sensação de
voar no helicóptero é completamente
diferente um avião que é muito melhor o
helicóptero no mundo é um pouco mais
estável mas é muito bom porque você
senta e mesmo o nosso corpo tipo assim
que o povoado é muito bom mesmo e eu
acho que ainda vamos fazer para pentear
o asa delta eu acho que sim né windows
asa delta agora porque é uma coisa assim
o ipatinga montanhas anos embora o
primeiro porque eu sei que não vou cair
a igreja não me chama as coisas mais
leves tons que andam mais logo não por
medo que eu vá e depois falamos com o
helicóptero nós vamos fazer uma viagem
turística como dentro do ônibus e o
nosso guia turístico era muito bom era o
poeta marcelo eu fui muito simpática
explicou que tudo muito bem e eu passei
a conhecer muita coisa do rio de janeiro
que não conhecia mas vejam só para sair
só trouxe aqui no ônibus não vim aqui
fazer uma visita turística vários
barzinhos é bem interessante é legal e
marcelo kiyota e agora vamos comer aí
meu o strokes outro lado o conselho é
centenária história o bicentenário esta
é muito bonito
ontem ficou depois desta viagem nós
somos um restaurante que já no nome mas
é o restaurante centenário
só deu terra come aqui dentro com uma
coisa muito boa eu comia arroz com
feijão que o time já no brasil é muito
bom eu comi uma carne que nem sabia o
que era não gostava do lixo rosa de uma
carga bem em rinha de como as coisas
neste país filete de carne por um site
será muito bom mas pra mim melhor foi a
sobremesa tipo a sobremesa é uma coisa
que eu nunca comi em nenhum lugar um
pudim só queria que eu pude porque o
pingo doce de leite eu acho que sabia
muito dos problemas é que um doce muito
gostoso eu nunca comi um pouquinho tão
bom na minha vida é só o melhor por mim
e uma do tamanho de purim no mundo era
não era o lá em casa eu vou fazer este
pudim eu não sei cozinhar é fácil para a
comida lá em casa eo perito a comida
suas formas nunca comi primeiro turno da
série b em poder eu vou fazer 16 acho
que eu não como sofás sobre magno
contudo como turismo magro e não como
jornada em inglês e depois de terem ido
a um restaurante nós fomos para o
redentor creta o cristo redentor que é
muito bonita é muito alto tem de 700
metros de altitude meu feijão e foi
muito louco já tá tudo entrar no cowboy
vejam só como está gigante pessoal daqui
dá pra ver tudo lá embaixo mesmo é muito
alto e ainda estiver mais aqui na escada
rolante
depois do cristo redentor se nós fomos
andar de teleférico a equipa aquela
caminhada na assim imaginem que eu
espero que um dia sim e depois jogando
assim num dia mas não é muita mas muita
técnica que o bilhete do ferro ok eles
venda proibida o window to venderam
bilhetes que jó 2 ea jeeps reais é r$2
lindo windows não pode ser estendido
proibida o indulto não pode comprar só
de rodar o estado divulgado chamar a
polícia ou ainda comprar um bilhete que
não é permitido a venda ou chamada
polícia o publisher ainda aprenderão ndó
polícia
aiaiai de empregadas ou não não vou
deixar o quadro mas mesmo isso álbum e
viagem conferir o vamos virar a tela
acima estudo é que muitos de hockey
empreendimento está muito feio que eu
pensei que fosse tipo 1 o valor mas não
é um feito fere cupão disso caso eu
pensava que instruiu o dorminhoco
federico é igual é uma coisa não estava
muito feliz e é muito e vai ganhar muito
é tudo era impedimento fere neném um
semestre muito medo de avião
assim é que nós vamos andar estava lá
tudo isso aí
em lyon a banda que já tocou de novo
aí o windows é muito alto nível é muito
alto
olha só aí olho aí meu tom como em cima
conta um sapo ea nós já tivemos jolie e
agora estamos aqui e é com essa mesma
altura ainda não expirou vá lei banho
indo assim mesmo nem sei o que passei
esse mas provavelmente não faz com a
consola que tem um homem que cantei no
bolso tanto fábrica de ser muito louco
mas não só como um teste muito rápido ao
esse é o confere cantigo e este é o do
fed também titular senhor do fed cup
etapa confere com o resultado serena é
muito bom é muito bom som sapato um
homem sapatênis ou deixar quebrar aqui
em baixo nunca mais pegar essa quebra é
muito alto aí que tem montanhas time de
novo em que não se conseguem ver muito
lento com a segunda subida vai ser a
tela e assim uma homem ainda falta muito
vamos buscar um segundo ferry que
estamos mais alcooleira muito alto mas é
isso depois de irem para casa descansar
e mesmo é por isso que eu vou fazer é se
resuma que o uso ea mas já não consegui
aguentar mas como estava muito cansado
mesmo e talvez só foi isso espero que
vocês tenham gostado já sabem inscreva
se aqui no canal deixei muito claro que
neste vídeo e espero que tenham gostado
fiquem bahia até a próxima